Our lesson today is about
Engineering sequences.
There are many advanced videos on this subject,
But this video is a good introduction to engineering sequences
It explains the meaning
This expression.
The first question is what is the meaning of succession?
Cascading is
A set of consecutive numbers.
For example, you have these numbers, which are not geometric series,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
These are consecutive numbers.
Not an engineering sequence, but only a sequence.
Cascading geometry is a special type of successive numbers
Or a special type of numerical sequences, where each number is in
Is the sum of a constant number multiplied by the number that has been accepted.
for example,
The first number in the sequence is 2, and you hit number 2
In Issue 3
The output is 6.
Then multiply the number 6 in, the output is 18,
Then multiply the number 18 by 3, you get number 54,
And so on.
If you want to continue the sequence, you must always multiply the number by 3.
If, you have at first
The first limit.
Use the a1 symbol for the first limit in this sequence.
Each time you hit the limit in the same number,
That number is usually called "foundation".
In this example, a1 is equal to 2,
The basis is 3.
For example, if you have
Engineering sequence,
And a1 is equal to 90 and the base equals
Negative 3/1.
This means that the first limit of the sequence equals 90,
The second image is a negative 3/1 in 90.
whats the result?
A negative result of 3/1 in 90 is negative.
Check the result, 3/1 hit 90 equals 30 and add the negative sign.
The third limit is a negative result of 3/1
In negative
And equal to 10.
My negative sign cancels each other so that the answer is positive 10.
The fourth limit is 10 minus 1/3
Is equal to 3/10 negative.
The fifth image will be a negative 3/10
In negative 3/1 and equal to 9/10 positive.
You can continue to calculate the cascading limits in this way.
That is the meaning
Cascading Engineering.
But you have to distinguish between two similar terms
In terms of words used
In both.
This name is consecutive,
It is a set of sequential numbers.
You have 2 here then 6, then 18. Or 90, then minus 30, then 10,
Then negative 3/10
Then positive 9/10.
These are called sequences,
But you can see the word series,
Or geometric sequences.
The word series is usually used to refer to
Total cascading limits.
For example, these geometrical sequences.
The geometric series of this sequence are 90 plus minus 30, plus 10
Plus negative 3/10, plus 9/10.
If, serialized
The sum of the cascading limits.
This is just an illustration of my successive and sequential terms
So you can tell them apart.
Now go back to the engineering sequences,
We try to resolve the issue around it.
Ahmed wants to practice jumping the bungee jumping with a rubber rope
From a bridge soaked above the water.
In the first jump, the rubber cord extends 120 feet (symbol of the foot unit with the symbol ft).
If, at the first limit a1 is the first jump,
The cord extends 120 feet.
To draw a table and write in the first column "jump", in the second column "stretch" ie
The distance the cord extends.
In the first jump, stretch the rope
Distance is 120 feet.
After that, when the rope recumbent it expands by 60%
From the first jump, and each time the rope is rebound
60% stretch of the previous jump.
If so, the basis for each limit in this sequence
Equals 60% of the limit that precedes it,
Or 0.6 hit the previous limit.
For example, in the second jump, the amount of expansion equals 60% of the first jump
Or 0.6 multiplied by 120
It is equal to 72.
Then in the third jump, the cord expands by 0.6 of 72
Or 0.6 multiply this amount.
0.6 hit 0.6 hit 120.
Notice in the fourth jump, to calculate the stretch you hit
0.6 at 0.6 in 0.6 at 120.
60% of this jump. If, every time you calculate 60% of the
Previous jump.
If you want to write an equation for this,
Based on the explanation here.
The expansion at the general limit (denoted by the symbol n) equals
0.6 hit 120
S n minus 1.
This can also be written.
The general limit is 120
Hit 0.6, S minus 1.
How did you get this equation?
The amount of expansion in the first jump was 120 feet.
When you subtract the value of n by 1, 1 minus 1 equals 0.
If so, 0.6 s
Equals 1.
This is the amount of expansion in the first jump.
Then in the second jump, you should subtract 2 from 1
Equal to 1, AS1,
Note that there is one 0.6 at the second jump.
If, exponent n is minus 1, because when the value of n is equal to 2, there is
0.6 one, and when the value of n is equal to 3, repeated 0.6 times, 0.6 multiplied
0.6
When n is equal to 4, you have 0.6 s3.
So, whatever the value of n, the equation is 0.6 s n minus 1,
Hit 120.
The next question is how much stretch cord
When the twelfth tremor?
Use the calculator now.
It is best to use the term "rebound"
Instead of jumping,
Because the question about apostasy.
You can replace the first jump by default.
This is not the wrong way, but the rebound is closer to
The significance of the question.
If, therefore, the first expansion corresponds to the number 0,
The first column is called a tremor.
After bounce # 0, you have the number 1,
Then number 2,
Then 3.
This makes the equation simpler.
They extend at the general limit of the recession
Equals 0.6 s, multiplied by 120.
Check the equation, at 0,
0.6 s 0, equals 1 multiplied by 120.
At the first bounce, 0.6 s 1. Note that there is one 0.6 at the first shock.
0.6 Multiply the previous expansion.
What about the twelfth tremor?
You have to compensate n
Number 12 in the equation.
Use the calculator.
120 hit 0.6 s 12
Equals 0.26 feet.
This means that after the twelfth tremor,
Ahmed will not move much.
Where it will move 3 inches after the twelfth hit.
Always make sure that the value is n
Proportional to the result you want to get.
Notice in this question, when you used the concept of the jump,
At the first jump,
You had to write the formula 0.6 s n minus 1.
But when you used the concept of scratching,
This becomes the number 0 echo.
This is logical, to be 0.6 s0.
This is the first echo, if you have 0.6
S1.
At the second echo, 0.6 s 2.
And so it became
The equation is simpler.